i saw dmx's i think he's working on an
album right now you watched the verses
whatever snoop yeah i did it was dope
yeah man they shouldn't have put x
against snoop though
now you know that was good for the
culture though it was it was i think
some of those battles it's like
it doesn't matter who wins like rizza vs
primo it didn't matter who won it didn't
matter
it was like yo it's rizza vs primo like
you just want to watch this just
enjoy it like who gives a [ __ ] who will
watch it
yeah they're talking like i think the
next oh the rick ross 2 chainz one just
got locked in
which would be crazy yeah swiss chains
got some records
i think i think a lot of people will say
ross but i think you got
i just when you just said that i thought
about it change got some right you know
of course rose got no i've already
thought about
i've already thought in my head when he
was titty boy who could beat two
children he changed his name he had
joints
think about all the features though nice
feature game is his
future run was crazy crazy yeah that'll
be wild like
i might add that he might have the
meanest feature run ever in hip hop
history it's either him or wayne
wayne had that run too like oh he was
going crazy but i think it's chains
james was on everything everything
bodied mercy
you know what i'm saying that's gonna be
a good one
i uh i saw you saw juicy j challenger
man naz to a versus battle
juicy j and nice no i mean it's not
gonna happen because that'd be
ridiculous
i don't see it no i don't see it either
that's a wild thing to do if you're
juicy j to challenge
nas come on bro but who do you i mean
obviously besides jay-z like uh who who
if you if you had to you know you you
have a close relationship with naz like
who do you think would be a dope
opponent to see
to battle him
go dan that's tough i don't know
i almost feel like it would happen
it would have to be him in hole i would
have to say it i'd almost have to be him
and hove
or somebody like
yeah or someone like snooper dmx one of
those like yeah
like like a nas and a snoop drink would
have been dope
that would have been dope uh
yeah i would say hello bro it would have
that would be that would be the most
that would make the most sense to me
for them to do because that's who's that
always been that rivalry